hi guys hi hi hey
um so i just wanna say this movie is so
beautiful from the songs to the
animation the animation's so good
margaret i wanna know uh what's it like
seeing representation on screen like
this seeing you know the chinese fable
of the moon goddess come to life
it's beautiful i think it's so amazing
and i think that it's time
you know we've been waiting for
something like this for such a long time
and i'm
so excited and just so moved and it's
really
important to have movies like this and
just a great thing for everyone to enjoy
uh ken what was it like for you you know
reading the script seeing the music and
everything
is it was there one thing that you just
knew you wanted to be part of this film
or was it everything
it was everything i mean i think from
the script to the story
um to an all asian american cast and
and you have this um and friends who i
go back a long ways with like margaret
cho and john cho and
sandra oh and phillip asu from hamilton
and kathy yong who plays fei-fei that
it's one of the most talented casts i've
ever been a part of
so really everything like drew me to
this
i want to know you know starting out in
this career did each of you have a
reach for the moon moment something that
you wanted so bad that you made happen
i think just being able to be a comedian
you know to me it was really this kind
of thing that was
um seemingly impossible just because i
never saw
asian american comedians and i never saw
asian american actors and it just never
seemed like something that could be real
and so it was like a rocket to the moon
in a lot of ways so that's really an
amazing thing that we could actually do
it
ken did you have a similar moment i saw
you shaking your head yeah or nodding
yeah i think the moment where um i could
leave my day job and do this full time
because i didn't think that would be a
possibility
and uh it's it's in showbiz is
incredibly hard even more so
for uh for minorities and and asian
americans and
asian canadians it's a hard thing and to
do
full time and um i think the moment that
i felt like i was able to do this
full-time
i i honestly felt like that was
that was my moon if you will yeah yeah i
love
that um you know when you're growing up
were there certain animated films that
you really connected with or certain
characters that you loved or inspired
you
oh animated um bambi
no i love them i still haven't seen the
scene where the mom dies i always
fast-forward that part
oh i just have to close my eyes it's
really
tragic it's really terrible
it's really terrible um i think bambi i
like the fox and the hound a lot too
um there's so many you know
it's just like um all of it all of it it
you know the world of it is so
incredible
can you have it yourself yeah everything
from like bambi
to mulan to finding nemo it's just
all the all the movies are just you know
in in my
in my head right now so it there there's
so many things that
that have informed all of us as actors
you know throughout our lives where
it just shows that you know animation
and good family stories are
are still important and still resonate
you know to this day
glenn keane who is directing this one i
mean he's
like an iconic animator behind little
mermaid beating the beast
aladdin i mean when you found out he was
directing was this like uh okay we're in
good hands
yeah he's amazing i mean he's just an
amazing director and you have to have so
much
um you just have to have so much support
when you're
really doing a voice you know so it's
really
incredible to work with them do you guys
feel like you're going to be seeing oh
no ken please
no i i echo that absolutely do you feel
like we're going to be seeing
you know this is obviously really
strange time right now do you feel that
we'll be seeing more animated films it's
just a lot easier to
not easier but just in terms of people
can kind of work on their own
in the booth like do you think we'll be
seeing more animated films
i think so i mean i also think that we
need a lot more
fantasy and optimism and joy
and a sort of a return to innocence in
childhood
so and a kind of a curated reality
in a lot of ways and so animation kind
of fits that
you know i think we do need like
something like
like let's go back to just like looking
at pictures because let's
deal with life i
agree i agree and i have to tell you
when this movie finished i've
i felt happier i was like i kind of
needed that like i really had such a
good feeling when it was done so thank
you
yeah well it was great talking to both
of you congratulations on the film
thank you so much
you